so you're a spoiled rich kid that's been
living a lavish life for 20 years but
now you want to show the world that you
can do more than drive around in Daddy's
Bentley so you pay a few thousand
dollars to teach English to some kids in
Kenya and build houses for the poor
locals once you arrive you take a few
selfies so everyone knows how selfless
you are but then you realize something
you have no clue what you're doing you
don't know how to teach English to those
kids you also don't know how to build a
house so you fail miserably and now the
local workers have to clean up your mess
on top of that the locals don't get a
single dollar of the money you paid for
the trip but who cares your Instagram
looks great your chances of getting into
a top college are higher now but these
poor communities are actually worse off
than before click the link in the pinned
comment to watch the full video